good morning Millennials welcome back
bro what's up it's Joe Jonas in the
house lead singer of the Jonas Brothers
very popular bands and now in this
minute I'm lead singer and I'm Nick
Jonas this is my little brother Nick
very talented I don't know why I'm
sounding like I'm from the Jersey Shore
but I am drew you are from New Jersey
brother Kevin's here too yeah hey Kevin
how you doing how you doing Kevin good
set it yeah cool cool cause I fan the
kids they're good yeah cute kids
favorite whoo Valentina looks like
you're a little stressed out with that
five o'clock shadow yeah you know
haven't been a dad you guys wouldn't
know but it's really hard Wow I'm
married man well yeah we're married men
love my wife Game of Thrones such a good
show my wife pre sure sure yeah you know
actually I mean Kevin had a discussion
we want to talk to you about that later
okay
okay boys welcome to the morning toast
this is a super popular podcast yeah
we're excited to be taken over today for
a Halloween very spooky episode I don't
know if you guys know this but the girl
Claudia who sits in this chair usually
uh she's a very good friend of mine very
very good I love that girl so talented
you know she understand what it's like
to be a star you know to be like to be
you know so musically talented she gets
it that's like and so that's why we
really connected Wow happy for you guys
bro thanks really happy for you bro
everything changes he'll accompany going
by the way I'm gonna ask you it's pretty
good ooh is that a cigar you certain
cigar company soon you know I just I
like how it looks
yeah looks good bro looks good first you
know I'm the first guy in the cover of
Forbes holding a cigar who didn't know
that you know I'm the I'm the first guy
to be the number one guy in this group
well we can't fight about that later man
okay it broke because I think we got
some business to attend to before that
yeah we got some business to attend to
welcome to the morning toast a very
spooky episode it's the Halloween
extravaganza our favorite day of the
year as you know last year we were the
Kardashians the year before that we were
each other we'll be going in and out of
character as the genius brothers this
year because we got to deliver in the
first five stories that you need to know
um but we also
are speechless over the end just Brad
catch this again you don't know the
words bro that's my thing you know I
can't remember all the songs from the
early days I promise you you left the
band oh yeah I mean I do think at some
point we should discuss you leaving the
band and whatever goes down here today I
don't want you get too upset and like
you know leave the band again you know
okay I mean I mean your promises but I'm
supposed it's all for the band guys I
mean my heart's in dnce anyway yeah we
know we know you and your band of
yellow-bellied losers actually today we
need to give a mature shout-out to Shawn
at Karaka suits who have these for us
yesterday in one day because they came
so late on Amazon I looked like a clown
and now I kind of looked just like a
hotter clown
I'm actually really digging the shadow
look and this short haircut you know how
I feel about pixie cuts they're like not
my vibe at all but I'm really like
liking the way that I look and calling
me crazy but I think I really look like
Joe Jonas he looked like someone and I
just I can't put my finger on what I
look like I look like Shane Dawson oh my
god no you don't but if you're wearing
Jackie's way wig you'd look like Chien
das in my wig is so funny just switch up
wigs later even though they technically
look like they're all the same they're
not shout out to the Raquel Welch wig
collection
yes well together Raquel Welch wigs we
actually went to a wig store yesterday
we wanted to go to like a fancy not just
like a costume wig store but it's like a
real wig store like in the middle of the
theatre district it was so hard to get
to and we went into the weights who are
you guys and it was I guess I guess like
it's hard to pay rent in New York so
they were part-time wig store part-time
sauna we work but you know harness to
try and ways in general like putting on
a wig cap putting it like it's so hot I
got a ponytail I would say that was that
store was 85 degrees I think that that's
where I made me sick 1,000% escalated my
sickness it was so hot and sticky and I
was wearing big chunky merch oh my god
also kevin has the flu there but Kevin
showed up to wear today because Kevin
doesn't let his brothers down
kevin is a team player well Kevin
learned his lesson when he used to let
his brothers him because his guitar
playing was just like not up to par yeah
and he like wasn't really in it to win
it see 100 right
riah without him that was so far job
yeah sorry I'm sorry about that bro
I just feel about that is my one regret
good I'm sorry bro you didn't deserve it
yo you guys so if you said the craziest
thing wasn't what she said bro man can't
tell you man bro can't tell you but it
was [ __ ] crazy damn bro ya ever say
anything funny no she's not fake I
wouldn't say she's funny but she's super
smart yeah yeah yeah beautiful beautiful
you love her I love her too bro family
forever man family forever family man
and I like how we have this trend of
doing family like costumes and they
don't want to like box ourselves in and
say we're always gonna be families but I
like wear it but I like fitted yeah I
think we should do a little performance
you know I'm just feeling musical
because I'm like so musically talented
as anecdote is like I'm just [ __ ]
music theory left and right so you want
to do the performance like the one that
we had scheduled for the show no we
could just like do a little jingle let's
let's jam bro let's let's do a little
like toast brownness okay like they said
I've been to the morning toast not much
has changed but they just as the Joe
Broz and your great-great-great and
Sneetches is you and I do
nailed it no so speaking of your singing
we actually recorded this is Jack and
Claudia now we recorded a great patron
episode last night that some are saying
is the best one yet which is seems to be
a pattern that people just say with
every episode but what we did was we
went through group membership questions
where people ad said if their attack
here at Claudia and it was incredibly
offensive we read some of the best ones
and was just a really funny episode
about like toasted inside jokes like
what people think of us and it was a
great reception from the from the
episode already yeah and then a lot of
people are commenting they do love your
style hmm sure whatever
I'm loving this style I'm a lead singer
so you know tell you stylist and stuff
you know when you're a star like me that
stuff just kind of happens for you yeah
okay cool man I'm a star I'm happy for
you to know that I am okay well actually
show three dates a demi song Nick would
never sing any song they're not notes
but like they're Tammy's coming around
she's making amends and I think we're
gonna be fine so I just want to support
her in this time people in the comments
have figured out who I look like don't
look ready Josh Peck no she doesn't Josh
Peck yes but you look like Josh Peck
dressing as a Jewish brother on Drake
and Josh
yeah a very specific costume oh man that
is so [ __ ] funny that's amazing well
it's getting more like the Beatles
oh you ever dressed like the because I
didn't even know Stevie Nicks was in
Fleetwood Mac yeah or also like I ya
know even though you know as Joe Jonas
I'm heavily influenced by the music of
the Beatles like one of the greatest boy
bands of all time you know obviously
except for the Jonas Brothers I'm more
of a Stevie Wonder kind of guy yeah but
that's just me you're different so what
how do you know John Varvatos bro you
want your tequila company with him how
do you guys know each other
yeah so it's actually a really really
great story it's just like when you're a
huge star like me and these are just
clamoring to drag me all the time you
know and then sometimes you just hit it
off with one of them more like that more
than another John and I we were ripping
stogies and we just decided like bro you
should start a tequila company yeah bro
so we did bro yeah always how it happens
dude yeah oh yeah bro bro man man bro oh
I'm sorry we are all amanda bynes and
she's amazing but anytime
a lifetime on the baby scoot by the way
word demon I cannot like put my hair
back or like wear a wig without being
told I look like Sebastian okay it's
crazy I think actually you just have a
face like Sebastian Sebastian didn't
have scruff and honestly he had less
hair than this I don't think you will
kind of look like him today yeah I don't
feel like Amanda Bynes as Sebastian like
when she's walking like I'm just like
feeling it okay you know who else I look
like someone commented joey camasta you
really did it right
you really did loving it loving it Kevin
love you bro cooter
love you bro bro bro how's it goin bro
you're not talking much that's really
unlike you I think it's very like me
what's up bro how much you know just got
my guitar a jewelry company has a gun
really well I heard that two men good
for her
whatever happened to married to Jonas
bro you think we're gonna get like a
season three I don't know it was really
hard on the Pam was it bro yeah having
cameras all the time mmm bro you guys
didn't like it either yeah well we were
you know back dad and we were just like
so focused on you know this great divide
caused by everyone else and it caused it
um
so X tinier behavior yeah it was all you
sudden you thinking like this they
you're the number-one guidance group
when it was clearly me like watch the
watched videos of us in the minivan like
I would I yeah bro there's a good reason
bro they're like all the executives bro
like one and me you know I'm the star
bro
lead singer I stand in the middle
sometimes sometimes I stand in the
middle yeah but everyone knows on number
one guy in this group okay happy
Halloween everyone today is just such a
spooky day really I mean I'm so hot in
this suit but I have chills because it's
very chilling yeah so we're gonna hit
you with a spooky episode I can't
believe it's finally Halloween it's been
Halloween for a whole week and please
don't tell me that people are dressing
up to sleep and they are sticky makes
they'll call did you make the wrong call
on the weekend no I think last weekend
was definitely the weekend tell pretty
celebrating this weekend it's like
losers who didn't have plans last
weekend no other losers who got the date
wrong yeah yeah who like didn't get the
memo who didn't run poles on their
Instagram so justified yeah but my
feeling is is like one since November
first even Halloween could be on a
Friday and when it hits that Saturday
November 1st
joy to the world the job yeah I agree I
agree I agree like after the the
Halloween season like there's not
there's the 12:01 12:01 greed it's
Christmas time in the city baby it's
cold outside
okay controversial though I'm singing
the Kelly Clarkson version not the hold
one yes love this new version we should
do a Christmas albums bro bro yeah like
Love Bug meets you know white Christmas
bro yeah like I'm speechless
over the edge and just breathless I
never thought that I'd catch this
holiday bug again yeah bro I'm gonna
more guy in this group and I'll just
stick to like you know being the star I
just want to say back to Jackie here I
heard myself singing on yesterday I hear
just I didn't want to confuse these
podcasters that they can't see I heard
myself singing on yesterday's episode oh
I'm sorry we have to man spread yeah and
I'm gonna put my mic is my little dick
yeah wow that feels much better much
better um I heard myself singing
yesterday's episode um and I just really
sounded like really nice Michelle did
actually like not turn not terrible at
all yeah and I thought that was pretty
cool
get out of my face hope get the [ __ ] out
of my face help are we ready to jump in
to the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite of your morning toast you sound
like a dude bro yo bro Carrie Underwood
[ __ ] slaves bro she does [ __ ]
sleep okay should I sing each headline
give me a tune bro I got a okay ready
give me a tune no no dice give me give
me a song okay ooh Caitlyn Jenner
celebrates 70th birthday without Khloe
Kardashian I actually saw this they all
want to know my Malibu like have they
ever been to another restaurant in their
land especially not for a birthday and
it's like why would you want to go
anywhere else like the best restaurant
in the world is Noma Malibu and like
they treat the Kardashians like the
president so I feel like this is good
for them and Caitlyn is so malleable
right she does live in Mal though she's
a local resident I remember the first
time I went into Malibu I was literally
driving around looking for healing
and never found our bro I'm sorry I'm
sorry about that
actually just a tenth of a Malibu
[ __ ] delicious um yeah good vibes
good food it's really pretty and like
good light honestly anyways
really cute that they all celebrated
Caitlyn's 70th birthday I can't believe
Caitlin 270 I know I know also never
know where they stand you know like with
you all like pretty much you you know
where all the Kardashian relationships
are at given like social media and their
show but with Caitlyn she's like never
really discussed and like whenever they
like post about her celebrate her I find
it to be shocking same with Rob but it's
less ambiguous something about Caitlyn
it's like they talked so much about her
in previous seasons like with the Vanity
Fair article and then right after her
transition there was so much talk about
her and then they literally stopped
talking about her for good yeah well now
this shows us where they stand and I
guess everyone's cool except for Chloe
which is kind of how it's always been
oh yeah Kendall and Kylie have always
been in the middle because they have
like they can't really take sides it's
both their parents but for the Jenner
for the Kardashian girls Bruce has
always been their stepdad so it's less
it's more complicated yeah but you would
think Kim's always having her mom's back
yeah was Kim there Kim was there and she
like posted a sweet message on Instagram
it actually all seems like pretty good
maybe Chloe was just busy okay no maybe
Kris is really like obviously Kris is
not gonna go but they're fine yeah I
think I think things are being smoothed
out much like in our family Ben getting
the band back together can relate to
this story bro bro like I know we're you
know we've moved on but I just want to
talk about you know that one day in
Australia like that was really important
and special to me bro like I'll never
forget it for the rest of my life bro no
I think we might have been in New
Zealand but I totally agree it was
beautiful bro whatever was oh yeah he's
voice Australia yeah how was that
experience for you it was [ __ ]
awesome bro finally you know being
treated like the [ __ ] megastar that I
am loved in real nice people
Aziz love you bro it was great
experience I would definitely do it
again maybe in America now people are
saying I do like Paul Masson thank you I
do
amazing that is so funny oh my gosh well
I'm happy happy birthday Caitlyn Jenner
yes HPD I can't believe you're 70 there
are a few people in the world whose age
Trulli shocks me like Trump is like 72
that is like the most shocking thing in
the world
adele is like 1 years old like she's
hardly be Taylor scriptor are the same
age yeah which is crazy because adele is
just like this wisdom behind her voice
that i think she's like 75 no I know
she's just like lived so much yeah and
like her music is so mature that you
think she's much older than she actually
is but she's not it's crazy
Chris Dom's yeah and it's I guess it's
because how old is Chris oh she just had
her big 60th and then it's like been 2
years since then so she's around like 62
6 I think she's turning probably 63 her
birthday's first week of November much
like mine what's good what are you gonna
do for your birthday
I'm just keeping it low-key everyone
keeps asking me I'm going to dinner what
else should I be doing I'm here so I
actually had this idea I was like a few
weeks back but um I don't think this is
the year for it but I'm gonna do it
eventually where I have like a massive
house party like at a loft where it's
like house party themed where it's just
like bread cups like like it's like a
basement party and I invite like
everyone I know bring whoever you want
like come through I'm so done that'd be
really fun and we just have like a major
dance floor like a DJ and we just be
like the party like the parties that we
used to have in college but like these
are adults there's no situation for it
to have a party like that now like yeah
now it is so hard to find a real party
agreed but um I don't think 27 is the
year to do it like maybe next year or
something okay I think I had a wedding
this year like that was that part I
agree also I know the Jonas Brothers
round tour but I'm doing my solo stuff
it's called the dirty jeans tour tickets
available although calm hitting up
Kansas City Rama Ontario Tarrytown New
York Verona New York Atlantic City New
Jersey Englewood New Jersey bunch of
shows coming up make sure you check it
out grow no job com it's gonna be a good
time bro good time bro good time so I
had a random thought this morning it's
beyond random that I wanted to share
with the class but I never thought I
would remember it and now I'm
remembering it because I was listening
to cash his new song raising hell I
haven't heard it but it's so good okay
and it made me realize that the movie
raising Helen it's like also a play on
the term raising hell
oh I never realized that either I guess
raising Helen is one of the best myself
I know you I know that's how you feel so
I just thought I would share like I
think her name was Helen like they made
it a place recently it looks like
raising hell oh that's interesting is
Kesha's new music good just it's this
one song it may or mean
be part of the Charlie's Angels
soundtrack I could know if she's putting
out an album okay well when I think that
Charlie's Angels soundtrack just Isis
[ __ ] I know but when I searched
Charlie's Angel Sanchez I was looking
for the old soundtrack because I watched
both of the old movies like with Cameron
Diaz and Lucy dude
I watched him this week and oh you
weren't there when I was telling
everyone um and they're so good
the - Charlie's Angels Cameron Diaz Lucy
Liu drew Barrymore like I highly
recommend okay and your guy matt LeBlanc
is in it that LeBlanc
who is he he plays Lucy Liu's boyfriend
who's a actor lol it's actually really
good and Emmet what's his name yeah
Wilson yeah the other Wilson brother
mm-hmm I like him thank you both
brothers Wilson meet you maybe next year
brothers Wilson yes I like them too
you'll have to get a prosthetic nose I
like them too yeah how come we never see
them together I can't believe they're
brothers no and they look so similar but
I don't think they've ever been within a
hundred feet of each other that you
would never even imagine that they'd be
related no like I don't think they've
ever met yeah you know yeah it's really
weird we need to get into the industry
first like Owen was more successful but
I feel like Luke's been around longer
yeah and I guess Owen like did Woody
Allen flick so like that's pretty
prestigious which one of you do minute
in Paris Midnight in Paris I happen to
just watch it it was cute is right did
you see it yeah but in theaters Oh
interesting is I I just liked it it was
more of like a romantic comedy than I
expected for what yonks I just feel like
his movies are so like if I thought that
like procedures right nobody it was cool
it was accessible yeah yeah I liked it I
liked it I think you got a receipt in
your pocket bro other one inside sorry
bro
what do you what do you buy a new
equipment for you too so look I might be
selling my suits on eBay wasn't doesn't
go well so just want to keep the tags
all right bro let's roll through to the
second story bro okay give me a tune
give me a tune
Kylie Jenner dressed up as Little
Mermaid Thor Halloween two three I'm
slippin into the lava and I'm trying to
keep them go we done
baby who turned temperature i'm
harmonizing and my voice my balls
literally baby who turned burning up
burning up for use tension love it
anymore go right now like kevin doesn't
sit like that bruh I'm sorry like
everything is hurting so I'm just trying
to get to heaven as the flu kevin has
the flu Kevin's just trying to make it
through I'm just trying to make it
doctor
no but I feel like this is how a man
sits you know with no care in the world
no yeah and Kevin is just like ride in
that 747 can't come fast enough has no
one ever heard that song by Lady
Antebellum 749 singing like for real
never miss 747 can't come fast enough
fast enough so every time someone's on a
747 like that's what I think about but
no their tour 747 yo they're [ __ ] I
mean our [ __ ] plane bro is so sick oh
my god that's all me you know the
executives let me so much bro yeah
thanks bro yeah that's good bro and bad
bro I mean me okay anyways there's not
that much celeb news right now because I
think all the celebrities are home
dressing up for Halloween you taking
pictures and they're not going anywhere
which seems to be the trend that I am
very much on board shame I mean like
right after this I'm gonna take a bunch
of pictures and go take a shower
yeah like poof my friends but then I
have these eyebrows on all day by the
way you know what like if we ever get to
a place where like we have our own like
studio or an office like we need to have
all of our wigs be on heads like as like
memorabilia around yeah like we could
have used last year's Chris wig for
someone yeah she's dead somewhere by the
way anyway you put on you just look like
Christina yeah you are a vegetarian
short wig I'm just Kris Jenner yeah yeah
I thought people would think we all just
just dressed up as Kris which also would
have been a very good idea yeah I would
have been here for it Kris would have
been here for it too
Oh bro yeah cigar broke I got a puff bro
sure my friend bro life is so good bro
life is good bro
so good okay so Kylie Jenner dressed as
Ariel from The Little Mermaid like so
topical and so beautiful yeah I mean
it's not the most inventive or creative
costume but she looks [ __ ] grain and
the glam was it was
the wig was great the outfit was great
oh great I wonder where she went I'll be
the storm is room yeah to wake her up
she's Shan yeah she should have just as
herself as rise and shine yeah just like
where that same outfit again yet and
she's really like having a week for
herself yeah yeah she went to sauces
playboy party she's really just like
they dressed up his eyes because they
got LASIK surgery and threw a party for
it oh really doesn't see that ya see
that either
yeah the you probably didn't notice
because they're wearing like latex
dresses that had like a huge eye on it
but is because they threw celebration
because they can see now who got latex
Latah LASIK Stassi and Kylie together oh
my god luckily she blogged it oh my god
the worst vlogger ever my god no talent
uh if you like we're Kylie Jenner and
you could really be anything for
Halloween because you have like hair
makeup everything team what would you
think so for me I really like love
Halloween costumes that are like
relevant and creative I mean Claudia now
know the Kevin Kem she's slowly falling
out of the frame no it's fine stay down
by the end shall be off-screen are we
slippin into the lava sure she'll be
that was so beautiful Kevin for costumes
like I really find like the best
costumes to be ones that are like um
creative and more like pop-culture
relevant like when I did blac Chyna and
Rob like I think that was the best
costume ever made so if I had like all
the resources in the world I would go
like the Nina Dobrev route like she
doesn't know he's nail it but she tries
to be relevant like last year the star
is born custom was like one of the
dumbest costumes I've ever seen but I
appreciated the attempt at like the pop
culture reference so I'm always gonna go
that route more than like the glamazon
yeah I want to talk about Nina Dobrev
for a second because she is really
trying to be too Halloween what Vanessa
Hudgens is to cochon yeah the face like
the face neighbor Vanessa Hudgens is
also the face of Halloween she is yeah
she's just like the face of style yeah
people really love her I mean I follow
her name it's like then she goes to go
to him it's not like she's even doing
anything or wearing anything like so
interesting but she somehow like said a
go touch Ella
yeah and I think Nina Dobrev is trying
to be the Halloween person who do you
think is the Halloween person though
right now right I always associated with
Paris Hilton I feel like she dresses up
20 times oh yeah oh yeah that's the
Halloween but I have to give major
shout-out to Lisa Rinna's costume this
year
and by the way I think a lot of the
people in LA treated last weekend like
the Halloween weekend extravaganza
because the Casa migos party was last
weekend and that's where like everything
goes down yeah that's the one and only
party so whenever the Casa migos party
is happening that's Halloween weekend oh
great and the world should like follow
yeah I totally agree and I agree that
Brenna's costume was incredible
incredible she did a whole a GTV story
of her giving glam look she's havin glam
for like three hours it was so long
that's crazy yeah yeah I always want to
have like one day have a makeup person
who actually can transform my face not
even with prosthetics but like with
contouring shadow and the freckles
yeah yeah because I always just do like
my own makeup I just do like a different
lipstick color you know yeah I mean you
guys can't see but I have a huge [ __ ]
brows right now and it was all I can say
it was all Mac well I have it look at
you on the camera you look like
different than from the side then
straight on well cuz I got a side part
goin which is you know new for me
this wig is so [ __ ] itchy yeah
the back of my way yeah the back of my
wig is good anyways I'm really I love
Halloween
but I'm really looking forward to being
over it's been a way too long about how
I like Halloween but I'm really looking
forward to the holiday season like I
could feel it in the air already like
the jingle the mistletoe like I just I
can smell the eggnog and I'm really
excited I'm really excited I can smell
your maple bass sin yes I mean it's very
autumnal in here it really is and I'm
really excited for the holiday season as
well you know gonna be good stuff bro
it's gonna be good stuff
Kevin how about you what are you gonna
do with the kids at Christmas yeah the
kids probably love Rockefeller Center
yeah maybe we're skating yeah bro you're
such a good kids so cute bro hope to be
a dad like you one yeah me too you're my
idol bro Thanks I look up to you bro
okay thanks for always being that
problematic bro next story is oh I have
to sing it I'm sorry um give me an
old-school Joe Broz beat ooh this is an
SOS ooh
bachelor paradise couple John Paul Jones
and tisha have split
she was just on the show in LA and I
didn't really get any you know warning
signs that they weren't together but she
was very trepidatious of just like how
she spoke about it because a lot of
people assume they're like gonna get
engaged soon just because they came from
Paradise but at the end of the day
they've really only hung out like ten
times so I wasn't like super shocked but
um it was confusing because she said
that they were gonna he was moving to LA
for her right yeah I'm not super shocked
at all I feel as though she what like
this actually makes a lot of sense and
especially I didn't even I thought my
question was done when I asked it which
was what are you guys gonna be for
Halloween but I feel like Halloween is
really a moment for couples like you're
gonna take pictures and you have to
requires planning and knowing we're
gonna be together on Halloween and then
they broke up on Halloween so I wonder
if they just were like wait like usually
people break up and then a few weeks
later they announce it and this is the
few weeks later right you also had a
great idea that you thought they were
gonna be Romeo and Juliet for someone
else said that I would love to take
credit but oh yeah because they did that
poem thing on the beach in Paradise if
you don't remember there's a lot going
on with bachelor nation recently which
is so you know great and just in time
for the resurgence there was naturally
the rebirth of the snapshot because if
she you need to discuss you to discuss
this you discuss Tammy Demi and
Christian because something's definitely
amuck and there's just lots of things
going on also he's a cheating on Kristen
Katie I haven't seen them in years and
you see that there was a I don't quote
me on this there was a post in the
toasters at someone's house and Chris
Bukowski making out at our house yeah
methinks that girl was majorly confused
and thought Kate Taoiseach was Katie I
saw that they just sounded so
unrealistic
and if you don't watch the show like I
just think that that girl okay
yes don't quote me on it Wow you know
that's a great call because I would have
just ran with that and been like so
house is a great place to make out with
someone who's not your man because no
one can take pictures of you yeah but it
just it that's so not tisha
no and when I when I read that it didn't
make any sense it should Chris Bukowski
annotation were like [ __ ] at so house
and I was like there's literally no way
if it means Kristen Katie are great
right that's what I thought I think that
you're definitely mixed up the to
understood okay well they're splitsville
I hope that Derek is gonna start
knocking on tatius door because I still
ship don't come knock on out
yeah no I Derek actually made a
resurgence on Instagram today I
apparently had been gone from Instagram
for three weeks and even though I'm in
love with him I had no idea and he's
like he's making a comeback keep
suffering from food poisoning even this
is podcast when I was back she was just
just in time to sweep Taoiseach off her
feet
yeah and just in time for the snatchler
the rebirth of the snatchler it's so
incredible it's gonna be like Easter you
know she's alive she she she's alive
just feeling like I was gonna report it
last night but then I was just like
that's her nation like I can't wait that
soon out yeah but I just want to
reiterate I'm more here for this niche
than I am for the snatch for the more of
it The Bachelor the lure yeah
okay next story a little New York City
news I love like just like random [ __ ]
then random laws are happening you know
yeah that's like something that ends up
on the bottom of a Snapple cap right and
this doesn't affect us at all but I'm
here your take did you ever hear the the
myth that the you know all the Snapple
cap facts have numbers yeah the number
one is that only 50% of Snapple facts
are true I've heard that myth yeah I've
never seen it though it's true um I
don't know I you can't call them facts
if they're not true right I don't think
they're true though some of them I don't
think some of them are true no some of
them like can't physically be true I
remember about one that was so stupid I
posted it on my Facebook what'd it say
it was something about how like if you
drop a ball of glass it won't break but
if you drop a ball made of rubber it
will that's definitely not trying I put
it on my I put it on my facebook cuz it
was like back in the day and I was like
pedo like know how how I heard an
interesting tidbit in my newsletter
today about like famous like myths and
this is what they had to say it wasn't
gonna cover it as a story but I think
it's interesting remember hearing as a
kid on Halloween to be careful of poison
candy or razor blades in apples yeah
those urban legends were actually just
that back in the early 70s and into the
80s police departments and politicians
and the media began to talk about a fear
of strangers using trick-or-treating as
cover to harm children almost out of
nowhere but it turns out there's
virtually no evidence of any child ever
being killed or injured by a stranger's
candy and the rumors just had to do with
more like anxiety
but I've seen pictures of razor blades
like coming out of Milky Way's you have
yeah I had that haven't I have online
crazy yeah but that was always the thing
the Apple of compassion biting into an
apple and there's a razor that's why I'd
like to know no one actually ever did
that that's why I don't need apples yeah
if you think about it though the whole
concept of trick-or-treating is like a
kidnappers dream like learning kids with
candy it's a crazy night you know their
parents are running around yeah it's a
crazy night All Hallows Eve spooky stuff
my friend Bona Bona by the word and not
go anywhere
Dahlia are you ready for this next story
that is a bit of news that doesn't
really affect us at all but I'm curious
to hear your opinion sure New York City
is banning what's gonna be [ __ ] Gras in
restaurants and grocery stores over
concerns why of animal cruelty but isn't
that the same thing as like chicken yeah
but I guess they're worried more about
the ducks why that's really odd no frog
rod snail
it's fat no that's a sparrow it's
fattened liver of a duck or a goose okay
I mean they should just ban it cuz it's
nasty yeah and honestly like they should
really use it as a trap like if you're
in a grocery store and there's someone
buying frozen foie gras that person
should be in jail anyways so I think
they'll be great like a trap for them
like you're waiting outside Whole Foods
like to see which hipster about the
frozen frog raw and you [ __ ] arrest
that [ __ ] you know your cuffs on them
and throw them in the slammer
yeah do you think there's now gonna be
like an underground foie gras like
prohibition sort of restaurant where
they're like coming to the back room
they'll give you the dough looks like
whatever um New York government ban
something it creates an illegal market
for it and we reported recently about
the the ban on flavored jewel pods have
you guys heard about a black market
started yet though I know but I I feel
like the ban hadn't started yet I
haven't tried to buy flavored jewel pods
in the last month so has anyone tried
went up to the band start because they
gave us two weeks to scoop up all the
jewel pods that he possibly could but
then I
dueling site and and now I just have a
bunch of like mint packs just in case I
go to a festival or something you know
just in case bro yeah I mean and I
probably will go to a festival bro even
though you know we never talked about
what the stagecoach lineup
give me did you'd be on the show I don't
think that would mean oh well I give you
exclusive because I heard about the
three headliners like once ago and if
you watch a toast you heard of your
first did you think you told us I think
you told us you told us we didn't talk
about it because like why we like we
weren't gonna snitch I'm so 90% sure I
did say the headliner is like a week
before
okay well the headliner is our Eric
Church Carrie Underwood and Thomas Rhett
Thomas Rhett and then which is fine
and the rest of the festival is really
not good the only person that I care
about is Sanjay you know the rest of the
festival is like so not good like I
actually might not go yo bros remember
when I performed at see Church with
Shania Twain bring over there yeah bro
that was uh pretty [ __ ] weird I
thought I crushed it bro yeah rosemarys
you do [ __ ] Shania Twain bro
noburo okay whatever you say bro um she
could [ __ ] get it bro she's just in
tune my friends into uh the stagecoach
line up yeah I was I've been planning my
whole life around stagecoach 2020 and
now I'm like why yeah I know but I mean
it'll still be fun and you go for the
vibes but like there's no Luke Holmes
there's none of like the people that I
[ __ ] stand yeah me neither
I was super underwhelmed by it and
unless there's like some you know great
opportunity there for work I don't know
if I'm gonna be like dying to go yeah
and it's just a lot of like real old
country vibes like Alan Jackson who you
must respect the hell out of and it's
almost as if they're like trying to
deter people like us to deter like
people who heard about it on The
Bachelor but then they partnered with
Bachelor people to write sponsored
stagecoach they're having an identity
crisis they're definitely not trying to
distance themselves from people like us
because they literally just paid Colton
and Cassie to do a sponsored post for it
right that's what I'm saying also people
like us we're not the back like the
people who are about it on The Bachelor
now we're gonna go to try and hook up a
club we are like we're like country we
fly across the country for country yeah
right Kevin dress a different country
festival there are so many I know like
there's one in Myrtle Beach
I love Myrtle Beach I think
Myrtle Beach where it all began
and yeah I [ __ ] love down and che bro
yeah we should collab with that collab
Susan bro that would be a great collab
it actually really would be yeah we
should do a little more country like we
did with Diplo even though that song was
wasn't it wasn't our best work no but it
was good I'm a little bit country um
anyways goodbye foie gras yeah this is
like a really random a lot of past and
it's like good to know that the people
in office in New York are you know
really focused on here that here are the
facts okay and now I'm now I'm
understanding fragra is a specialty food
made out of fat and liver of a duck or a
goose according to CNN the dish is
prepared by force-feeding the animal in
order to fatten up its liver which many
see as a form of animal cruelty The
Times reported that the forest feeding
process requires tubes to be inserted
into the Ducks throat for 20 days the
animals liver reportedly swells up ten
times bigger than its normal size and
the Ducks can sometimes become too big
to walk or breathe oh my god this is so
sad that is going to be a no from me dog
yeah I mean I've never eaten fragra um
and now I never will and now I never
will I'm so sad yeah I'm I'm here for
this who knew who knew whose [ __ ]
gross idea was that no no like what a
freak owned a duck and was like I want
to fatten him up and then slaughter not
even that like okay makes sense I want
like a fat cow so I have more meat
I want to fatten up his liver and eat it
you have you guys a chopped liver
not on purpose I took a very Jewish dish
and I'm thinking actually even is liver
is it
it's like liver in addition to you know
all the other things like it's not just
straight-up liver it's disgusting
there's other ingredients like some
seasonings and other things I'm hoping
please yeah but honestly good New York I
changed my mind on the stiches situation
I didn't know that and it's [ __ ]
terrible yeah and everyone I think is
gonna be okay if they're not eating them
right you know the six people who were
waiting for the frozen foie gras at
Whole Foods will be okay
yeah okay fifth and final story is
really crazy news that this not sure
just airdrop to me and even though I
don't really care about these people I
care give me a tune give me a tune
Burroughs woke up Hannah Browns ex Jed
Wyatt just casually went official on
Instagram
the new girlfriend he needs to stop he
needs to stop he needs to stop I can't
believe has a new girlfriend he [ __ ]
with D him yeah well that's the other
thing like I don't know what species
would even think about dating him but
like he just can't win like he could
literally cure cancer people would still
hate him he needs to really get off
Instagram I can just go back to living a
private life but I don't think that's
what he wanted I think he's like he's
one of those like villains who like
loves like the variety yeah okay well
cosmo is reporting that jed Wyatt has
found someone new to date and it looks
like she's willing to pass look past his
messy Bachelorette scandal Jed hit
Instagram stories on Tuesday and made it
all kinds of clear that he's in a
relationship with a personal trainer and
model named Ellen Decker she showed up
in multiple posts from Jed where they
were seen eating a giant burrito and
enjoying the Miami view hmm but as we've
learned like going on vacation with a
girl doesn't mean anything right that
doesn't mean to him that their
interrelation love my music we did for
cool in Miami shut down downtown that's
cool yeah we were cool yeah no I was
cool I was feeling so cool top to the
bottom just cool every little thing that
I do damn it I feel so cool to Dan and
I'm feeling so cool yeah that's such a
good song where I loved writing that
song you know by myself from yeah but
you're super cool super cool bro it's
super cool weirdos the past five um
those were the Fast Five I just can't
believe that Jed actually has a
girlfriend like and this girl I mean I
guess like any thirst monster will take
like the opportunity that's given right
you know you and Priyanka would know
best whoa bro don't insult my wife I
know I'm sorry bro that was uncool bro
I took it back I love her I love I
actually really do I'm like totally a
believer of Nick and pray meet you but
who are your favorite and gay couples oh
so Joe yeah me too bro um but they've
been super quiet recently yeah well I
think they were so loud like with the
resurgence of the Jonas Brothers
happening at the exact same time as the
Game of Thrones finale like they were so
famous I think they probably just want
to break like yeah no I meant Nick and
Nick and cream Oh
they're trying to kids or something
maybe or maybe they're just busy like
living their lives being happy sniffs
you look more and more like heaven like
it's crazy oh no like Caprio Housewives
of Dallas and then we well what a boring
upside then we're [ __ ] breaking up
the band yeah Wow of course you would
say that by the way one of the worst
episodes of Real Housewives of Dallas
I've ever like had to sit there I found
it to be painful the only thing I found
to be interesting was that book that
court Westcott put together for Cameron
of him doing dishes as porn I'm just
getting more and more obsessed with them
as a couple agreed I just thought it was
so boring him a bunch of meaningless
conversations they like wanted another
episode before the actual wedding I'm
just bored to tears except I actually
really like Lance wedding dress yeah it
was sweet what happened on this episode
they went to go see her wedding dress
Tiffany was there Stephanie came and
Cameron was talking about the shower
again yeah also the wedding dress
designer was explaining how she was
trying to bring out the child and LeAnn
and it's like oh she was talking about I
was like the bride is a child and it's
like that's disgusting and I just
thought that was a really weird way to
phrase it
then DeAndre Brandi and Kerri
Brittingham went to lunch talking about
whether or not they were gonna go to the
wedding and Kerri decided that she was
gonna go to wedding brandi is going to
the NBA Draft with Bryan so she's not
going and DeAndre was not invited
finally yeah okay then everyone's having
parenting issues because Brooklyn is
literally the devil oh my god I really
felt for Brandi what is what should she
do I don't know and it's like I totally
understand what she's saying it's like I
I mean I've never been a parent but
i-i've imagined that the difficulty like
wanting to be strict but not too strict
that it causes the kid to like you know
hate you for like him and rebel um and
she's really struggling because she's
she's strict but she's not like Stern no
like if I were her I would take that
razor and I would drive it and throw it
in a dumpster no I would literally take
her Lexus and just drive over it ya know
I'd put the kids to see it or I could
put it in the car and I'd knock it in
the car and every day she walks past the
car and she sees her razor and she's not
getting it but I want to talk about the
more problematic child which was Olivia
braiding oh my god holy [ __ ] I actually
went to go stark ranch grimy austere day
because I wanted to see if she like was
like thirsting like like posting about
the show she it's like the her and her
family and Carrie hung out with Bronwyn
they went to OC and was like OC x OD
that was her so she's like living for
the fame and I just
she was more rude than ever to her mom
while she was making her problems just
like I couldn't just keep school mom I
like him a prom dress like she was so
[ __ ] nasty I wanna go to camp in
Europe like sewing camp she said Kay no
mom not sewing camp like no so [ __ ]
angsty I hope she watches that back and
is mortified because first of all you
shouldn't speak to anyone that way but
let alone the woman who gave you life
like she was so [ __ ] rude and there's
for me I hate kids who are like mean to
their parents I just have a friend who
was like her mom like would let her talk
show down to her and like never did
anything and like she's to do it because
she thought it was cool and it's like no
that's disgusting and disrespectful and
this girl Libby as I probably at that
age when she like thinks it's cool to be
mean to her mom but like you look like
an [ __ ] and it's like even if you're
mean to your mom normally which is not
right
but then there's cameras like and so
this is and so it's not like oh someone
was recording me like this is the image
that you want to portray to the world in
like you think that this is a good look
like I'm telling you the more I watch TV
I don't know why this is just a common
theme it's just making me like so scared
to like raise children
you know kids are animals this is and is
it these days is it parents I don't know
remember the tick-tock I showed you
yesterday
oh yeah but like Carrie is and Brandi
like such good moms in Bernie's other
daughter is really sweet maybe she's
just not at that age yet and I just I
what's the rhyme or reason you know yeah
I guess this is like an eternal question
like parenting you know it's always
gonna be like there's different styles
and just kids all kids are different but
I don't [ __ ] know I was just like I
don't know what I would do I my kid ever
spoke to me the way that girl let me
spoke to her mom
I [ __ ] slap her upside the head yeah
but he would have like it must have
started earlier like once she's 20 like
you can't really discipline him but like
a kid who when Kerry was in her house
sitting on the floor she was like where
you going mom I told you a hundred times
going out like that girl was definitely
going to a club with a fake ID right and
it was a weeknight and she was acting so
nonchalant about it her mom gave her
what like a [ __ ] midnight curfew on a
weeknight
like count your blessings Canty
blessings but other than that it was
incredibly boring episode um yeah I need
rich to stop making the jokes like is it
too late to run like it's not funny yeah
but at least he like he makes those
jokes and and he laughs and says I'm
kidding like it's not like Emily's
husband from OC who makes those jokes
and then doesn't say it's just like
deadpan also when they pulled up to the
chapel in a Bentley
where they
get that Bentley no she called him
Richter is that his name
oh I don't know maybe it's just like we
call her service man yeah you know I was
just when I said come on Richter and I
was like what did you just say that's
funny
also did you see that ermes kelly kelly
that she had there's something and I
don't understand like I understand that
their deaths everyone knows well from
the show but like that bag is maybe 15
20 grand
do you enjoy to eat it at her last night
and she wouldn't pay ten thousand
dollars for a wedding dress she answer
said how come you how can you afford an
Hermes bag but not your own wedding
dress and something is Emily I'm glad
you said that something to be confusing
because if you added up all the wardrobe
that LeAnn wears on the show it from
bags jewelry clothing accessories she
wears Gucci in every single scene she
probably has an a more valuable wardrobe
than anyone she's like on to REITs level
and Doritos you know a hundred percent
she wears nicer clothes in any of the
women every every every belt is Gucci
every earring Chanel like every
everything uninhabited sweater is Gucci
yeah even when she's just hanging around
she's wearing Gucci but she can't afford
a wedding dress not only that she has
positioned herself like she speaks a lot
about how she's not like the wealthiest
one of the criminal but it's like why is
no one compute its I would be I hope
someone brings it up eventually I just
I'm sure there's a logical answer but I
just want an excellent maybe she loves a
real the real real right or like uh Rent
the Runway yeah no it's not it's not
it just it needs to be addressed because
then when she was sitting at her lunch
with her husband before her wedding and
she's wearing an Hermes Kelly tags I was
Chuck Oh people are saying it's fake I
don't think it's fake I don't think it's
Vikki there it all seems very on-trend
there's no way it's authentic okay I
think there's no way that it's fake I
don't think you go on TV wearing fake
Gucci every single day yeah that's
really brazen
and that Hermes bag did not look fake to
me and none of it has ever looked fake
and she was wearing like a guichen for
example when they should be there when
she gave me her she was very old Gucci
and was totally right when I can
undertake belts here and there sure but
when she when they went to the haunted
house thing she was wearing a red Gucci
sweater with the Paramount logo and
sequins like that is a real Gucci
sweater right it's it's in stores right
now yeah and it's a couple thousand
dollars it's very confusing I've always
thought that oh and I wanted to talk to
you about Deandra and her mom because
I'm starting I think I've always been on
Deandra
side but I'm starting to see D side a
little bit where it's like she doesn't
like she gave Deandra a company which is
more than most people ever getting yes
it's not in a good place but Deandra has
every tool at her fingertips to make it
a successful company she's on TV right
now like she she should be doing launch
parties like every other businesswoman
right and stop wasting all of her
airtime on fighting with her mom and
focus it on promoting your damn business
yeah like and when Jeremy said like the
products are great that's the first time
I've ever heard that yeah
like talk to me about the products also
Deandra really looks incredible for
she's crazy she's one of the oldest ones
I think she might be older yes she's 50
um so like tell me what you're using
she's just squandering this opportunity
and now I'm seeing a little and even
though I would be like bothered if I
were Deandra because like she left her
like a real career that she had been
working towards to work for her mom like
she's I see where Dee's coming from
where it's like make it work yeah and I
think the timing of when her mom gave
her the company is definitely
intentional like Deandra is really like
a staple on the show I don't think she's
going anywhere like she really can use
the show to leverage her entire business
and when her mom gave her the company it
was right at the height of all that and
she hasn't used that at all and that's
like I've been saying I say every week
the fact that we still don't know the
name of the andrews company is why she
is not a successful businesswoman right
she's on the biggest platform in the
world probably with it within our
audience that's the ideal demographic of
her skincare is it it's like the
neighbor saying Christian TV like the
audience isn't there anymore yeah cuz
they're all watching Real Housewives
yeah oh my god by the way Christian TV
audience is definitely Bravo audience
yeah there's definitely some overlap
anyways oh my girls are my god losing
blood flow to Marion literally the back
of my head is gonna [ __ ] just like
crumble I don't know how [ __ ] Kim
Biermann does it but these brakes are
not snatched okay well we got a we got
to go because we've got a sick snitch
but before we do we have a little treat
for everyone oh my god would you uh
bring me my guitar
[Music]
you could sit next to Jackie yeah here
just come in we're gonna put together a
little performance for you guys one of
our favorite songs just give me a minute
to a pull up my sheet music we're very
sheet music heavy show yeah these days
no I can do it here we love our sheets
okay hey bro Hey Oh bro
Rob actually I might need you to hold it
for me ready mm-hmm
nice flying down the ten bears to
happiness begins days
lifted in a haze we when just a phase we
were just pretend I remember low lows
and I threw my hands up palms out to the
sky yeah yeah one two three
it was fun when we were young and now
we're older those days and we were broke
in California we were up and down and
better made it over but I'd go back and
ride that roller coaster with you dude
just free-balling on the guitar it was
fun when we were young in our older
those days that we were broke in
California we were up and down and back
uber but I go back and ride that roller
coaster with you happy Halloween
whoa I'm the lead singer of this group
don't you forget it everyone have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday's episode November 1st the
holiday season is upon us just don't
snatch it back the snatch it's [ __ ]
bad thank you everyone have a wonderful
day we will see you tomorrow happy
Halloween trick or treat don't let the
bedbugs II second with the shilling 2/3
runny chill celebrate safely
you